foreign
[Music]
Honey Boo Boo is officially a class of
2023 graduate we're doing really really
good honey boo boo real name Alana
Thompson graduated high school on
Saturday in front of a packed gymnasium
in Mcintyre Georgia a crowd that
included her famous fam her mom mama
June Shannon sister Lauren Shannon AKA
pumpkin and sister Anna Cardwell better
known as chickadee
Mama June shared that clip to Instagram
writing in the caption I'm so proud of
her she is our 2023 graduate and yes we
was hollering the whole time pumpkin
shared the same video and two pics of
her sis in her cap and gown alongside a
lengthy caption that read in part to say
I'm proud would be an understatement
amazed at how much you've grown how
beautiful your soul is and most
importantly how far you've come Against
All Odds being the guardian of Alana and
being the mother to La as well I have to
protect them I have a job pumpkin
wrapped up her sweet post writing that
she will always be her sister's biggest
fan and will always be screaming the
loudest for her
I'm very impressed with Ivana like
considering where she was two years ago
both of us like in the state of mind
that we were in the situations that we
were going through we really have
overcome that chickadee was also in
attendance posing with her sister
wearing a yellow wrap on her head the
reality star was diagnosed with stage
four cancer earlier this year and is
undergoing chemotherapy earlier this
month she shared an update with fans on
Instagram writing that the treatment
appears to be working so things are
looking good as for Alana and her mom it
appears they've done some healing of
their own she has to be willing to one
put in the effort
I'm like she's so angry at us for
holding on to the past but you have to
understand the past is so big last year
during an episode of Mama June Road to
Redemption Alana was debating inviting
June to her graduation ceremony I'm
gonna graduate soon but like should I
even advise you to my graduation because
like are you even going to come she's
not going to be there just because she
wants to be there well June was there
and couldn't have been more proud of her
baby girl writing that the road hasn't
been an easy one but Alana never gave up
and on Monday June shared a side by side
of Alana now and Alana as a kid when we
first met her on Toddlers and Tiaras I'm
Alana I'm six and I'm a beauty queen
that would make me hella Honey Boo Boo
now her baby's all grown up and Mama
June says she'll be by Alana's side
every step of the way a lot of the
relationship is going good and their our
door is always open
um no matter how old they get or where
they're at in life
um so you know Alana knows that the door
is always open
um she knows that I've always been here